Calgary's little world's daycare was
locked up tight Tuesday to the
frustration of parents and their kids
it's more about him and his needs not
being met because the Alberta Government
the federal government and child care
providers cannot find a compromise
dozens of daycares in Calgary Edmonton
and Lethbridge took part in the one-day
protest organized by the Association of
Alberta Child Care entrepreneurs an
advocacy group of small business owners
whose stated mission is to keep private
Child Care a choice for Alberta families
our intent was never to cause disruption
or inconvenience but really to raise
awareness so that our families and our
parents here know what's actually
happening under this agreement and the
future of child care Alberto was one of
the last provinces to sign on to
ottawa's $10 a day child care plan back
in 2021 we fully expect that all
provinces and territories will execute
on their agreements they'll follow
through on the commitments and I'm sure
Alber will be no exception to that
Alberta has until 2026 to roll out the
program but the details of that roll out
are causing operator concern the
protesting group is asking for more
Public Funding and fewer restrictions I
actually think that there's you know
some legitimacy in some of the concerns
and we've been hearing these across the
country the funding is too slow it's not
the systems have not yet been developed
which they should have Alberta isn't the
only province exper experiencing
challenges reduced fees have seen an
increase in demand leaving Child Care
spaces in short supply that's why over
the last year we launched two space
creation grants one for the um nonprofit
side and another just this summer for
four profit operators Alberta's
shuttered daycares are scheduled to open
again Wednesday morning though the group
warns More protest closures could be
coming Canada may be on the road towards
an affordable child care system but
there are still bumps along the way
Heather urex West Global News Calgary